dieses radiosignal aus dem zentrum
unserer milchstraße ist wirklich
besonders mysteriös das signal blinkt
und wird mit der zeit hundert mal heller
und dunkler astronomen den astronomen
weltweit sind verwundert alle gängigen
erklärungen scheiden aus was steckt also
dahinter klick substanz in future die
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannendes
seien sowieso abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen für diese
ungewöhnlichen signale aus dem zentrum
der milchstraße gibt es bisher noch
keine wirklich plausible erklärung dem
astronomen seating wangen von der
university of sydney gelang diese
mysteriöse entdeckung mit der hilfe des
australischen teleskops australian
square kilometer erwandert teleskops cup
und die verwunderung ist riesig so etwas
haben wir noch nie gesehen die
detektierten radiowellen passen nach
ansicht der fachleute zu keiner
bekannten art von quelle und auch die
polarisation des lichts gibt rätsel auf
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam in der
aktuellen studie zuerst dachten wir es
könnte ein poser sein also ein sehr
dichter und schnell rotierenden sternen
rest kam auch ein stern mit gewaltigen
eruptionen wurde diskutiert doch die
signale aus dieser neuen quelle stimmen
mit nicht überein was wir von bekannten
stellaren objekten erwarten was weiß man
bisher über diese mysteriösen
radiosignale wie genau wurden sie
entdeckt und was könnte dahinterstecken
die spannende antworten auf all diese
fragen gibt es jetzt hier partie zum
tanzen führte bereits anfang vergangenen
jahres 2020 gelang dem australischen
forschungsteam die spannende entdeckung
offenbart wurde das signal mit dem
austrian square kilometer ray pathfinder
teleskop es gab dann folgt eine
beobachtung mit den radioteleskopen
parks rund mehr cut spannender weise
konnten andere teleskope wie etwa das
röntgenteleskop des satelliten chandra
oder der nasa forschungssatellit
nigerias trifft observatorium das signal
nicht erkennen im februar bzw april 2021
aber dann gelangen dem südafrikanischen
mehr cut radioteleskop
und dem austria teleskop kompakte
reyaca.de treffer und das obwohl sie
ebenfalls frühere signale nicht
aufspüren konnten wie kann das sein ein
objekt das zunächst unsichtbar erscheint
dann heller wird und sich dann
abschwächt um dann wieder aufzutauchen
dieses verhalten konnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
im vergangenen jahr im laufe von neun
monaten insgesamt sechs mal beobachten
als die beobachtung dann mit dem meer
card radioteleskop gelangen gab es für
die wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
eine weitere kuriose erkenntnis dazu
heißt es in der studie als nächstes
versuchen wir dann mit dem meer card
radioteleskop in südafrika unser glück
doch jetzt stellten wir fest dass sich
das verhalten der quelle dramatisch
verändert hatte nun verschwand die
quelle schon binnen eines einzigen tages
obwohl dieser vorgang zuvor noch mehrere
wochen gedauert hatte dazu kommt die
aufgespürten radiowellen weisen
verschiedene charakteristika auf die
sehr ungewöhnlich sind zum einen die
zirkuläre polarisation kurze erklärung
polarisation bedeutet dass wellen sich
in einer ebene bewegen also zb so auch
von abt sich bewegen oder so auf und ab
sich bewegen oder eben komplett
durcheinander polarisiert sind sie wenn
sie nur das in einer ebene machen
erstens sind polarisierende radio
quellen sehr selten also solche extrem
ja in einer ebene ausgerichtete zudem
zeigt sich die art der polarisation als
äußerst rätselhaft denn sie schwingt
zwar nur in einer richtung rotiert aber
im zeitlichen verlauf zunächst dachten
die fachleute deswegen dass es sich um
einen flackernden stern oder ein pulver
handelt damit werden in der fachwelt
rote sterne bezeichnet die bei
supernovaexplosionen zurückbleiben und
radiowellen in einer schnellen und
regelmäßigen rate aus senden doch diese
erste vermutung wurde schnell verworfen
denn weder die charakteristischen pulse
nur spuren in anderen wellenlängen
konnten ausfindig gemacht werden dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam dieses
objekt war insofern einzigartig als dass
es zunächst unsichtbar war dann hell
wurde dann verblasste und schließlich
wieder auftauchte dieses verhalten war
außergewöhnlich unter tausende von
quellen finden wir vielleicht weniger
als 10 zu cola polarisierte quellen bei
fast allen handle sich um quellen die
wir gut kennen die pulsare die schnell
rotierenden stark magnetisierung
überreste explodierter stern nicht nur
die art und weise der polarisation ist
also für die fachwelt rätselhaft auch
die helligkeit des objekts die um den
faktor 100 deutlich variiert die ist
äußerst merkwürdig teilweise scheint das
signal komplett an und dann wieder
auszugehen anfangs sei das signal wochen
lang aktiv gewesen
doch nach nur einem tag verschwunden das
alles setzt das australische
forschungsteam für ein großes rätsel
worum könnte es sich hierbei handeln die
astronomen astronomen gehen davon aus
dass das signal aus der richtung des
zentrums der milchstraße kommt ist diese
erkenntnis wichtig damit das mysteriöse
phänomen erklärt werden kann fragen über
fragen die zum größten teil noch offen
sind die fachleute fassen ihre
beobachtungen folgendermaßen zusammen
die merkwürdigste eigenschaft dieses
signals ist ein sehr hoher grad an
polarisation das bedeutet das signal
oszilliert nur in eine richtung aber
diese richtung rotiert mit der zeit die
helligkeit des objekts variiert
ebenfalls stark mit einem faktor von 100
und das signal schaltet sich in einem
kristall zufällig erscheinen musste ein
und aus wir haben bislang noch nichts
vergleichbares beobachtet doch das
australische forschungsteam hat auch
einige mögliche erklärungen am start
denn manche der nachgewiesenen
eigenschaften erinnern an die
sogenannten galactic center radio
champions league
auch hierbei handelt es sich um wirklich
rätselhafte signale vorübergehenden
niederfrequente funkwellen in der nähe
des galaktischen zentrum solch eine
quelle leuchtet schnell auf und klingt
dann nahe des zentrums der milchstraße
wieder ab lediglich drei solcher
electric center radio transitions gc ats
wurden bislang offiziell aufgespürt in
den 2000er jahren wurden genau diese 3d
cad objekte identifiziert bei weiteren
steht noch die identifizierung aus doch
neben einigen möglichen parallelen
weisen die neuen mysteriösen
radiosignale aus dem zentrum der
milchstraße auch deutliche unterschiede
zu den gc objekten auf die eindeutige
identifikation als electric center ray
chen sion gc kann somit nicht erfolgen
dieses rätsel um die mysteriöse
radiosignal erinnert an ein phänomen das
im vergangenen jahr die fachwelt in
aufregung versetzt hatte ein kosmischer
radio blitz der alle 16 tage wie ein
uhrwerk signale aus dem all sendet wir
hatten hier bei exxon saint lucia
darüber berichtet diese entdeckung war
eine premiere denn dabei handelte es
sich um den ersten regelmäßigen radio
burst überhaupt dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam dies ist die bislang
erste und einzige bei einem radio gast
nachgewiesenen periodizität zwar wussten
fachleute bislang bereits dass es
sogenannte wiederholungstäter gibt also
quellen die ganze serien von radio birds
aussenden doch diese treten wohl nur
sporadisch und unregelmäßig auf doch die
signale die pünktlich alle 16 tage auf
der erde ankommen stammen wohl aus einer
spirale galaxie die 500 millionen
lichtjahre von der erde entfernt ist
zurück zu dem mysteriösen radiosignal
die das australische forschungsteam
aufgespürt hatte klar ist dass die
fachleute alles daran setzen wollen die
mysteriösen radiosignale weiter zu
beobachten dabei hoffen sie auf das
gigantische square kilometer mit dessen
bau aber gerade erst begonnen wurde in
neun jahren 2030 soll dieses mega
teleskop an den start gehen und 100 mal
empfindlicher sein als jedes andere
aktive radioteleskop seine infrastruktur
soll sich über drei kontinente auf der
nord- und südhalbkugel erstrecken sein
hauptquartier hat die einrichtung in
großbritannien tausende einzelne
antennen und hunderte von
parabolspiegeln bilden zwei
beobachtungsnetz werke die sich über
hunderte kilometer in südafrika und
australien erstrecken die gebaute
antennen fläche des mega teleskop soll
dann eine million quadratmeter betragen
und eine schnellere durchmusterung des
himmels möglich machen als je zuvor
heraus kommt dabei nicht nur
50 mal höhere auflösung als die
bildauflösung des
hubble-weltraumteleskops sondern zudem
auch eine unvorstellbare menge an
beobachtungsdaten die verarbeitet werden
muss das werden nur die schnellsten
supercomputer der welt schaffen und auch
die ziele des projekts sind wirklich
mehr als ehrgeizig unter anderem soll
ein 3d weltraum atlas erstellt werden
der uns einen blick in das frühe
universum ermöglichen könnte auf der
dunklen energie und außerirdischem leben
könnten wir mit hilfe von square
kilometer endlich auf die spur kommen
kein wunder also dass die australischen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
auf dieses meisterwerk der technik
hoffen möglicherweise lässt sich dann
eine erklärung für die mysteriösen
radiosignale finden nach ansicht des
studienleiters wann könnte es sich
möglicherweise um eine neue klasse von
objekten handeln die nur mittels radio
emme ging durch muster überhaupt
sichtbar gemacht werden kann mysteriöse
signale aus dem all wer oder was steckt
hinter den periodischen radio blitzen
hier geht es um die radio blitze die wie
ein uhrwerk alle 16 tage auftauchen ein
ebenso spannendes signal also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren nicht vergessen
bis dann bleibt dran